so we all know that Yoshioka care is a
man who enjoys himself a good old
sammich however a lesson in fact is that
after Kyra and his lady friend enjoy
subscribing to the new old review for
regular Jojo content uploaded straight
into their YouTube feeds and given how
many partners Kiera tends to have this
means that he needs to subscribe an
awful lot of people so thank you Kiera
I think hello and welcome to the new old
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today I would like to dive
back into the realm of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure in order to discuss a figure
whom I believe is not only one of the
greatest antagonists in the entire
series but quite possibly storytelling
in general and you know it's really
interesting when you examine Jojo
villains and come back to ask yourself
the question of well who's the best and
why because there are a slew of really
iconic figures to choose from could the
greatest antagonist be in the form of a
super vampire body thief who can stop
time well how about a figure literally
referred to as the ultimate life-form
then again perhaps it's quite possibly
the single most powerful figure in the
series who literally reshaped an entire
universe well maybe even a certain mr.
president well in my opinion it is none
of them and for all of their glorious
displays of power and intent I'm afraid
that the most effective sinister and
intriguing antagonist spawns from a
human who wanted nothing more than to
live a quiet life and bothered by the
world at large that is the goal of one
Yoshi cog Akira and his journey is
nothing less than morbidly captivating
although it only forms a portion of this
character who is unique even for a
series known almost exclusively for
unique individuals but I want to begin
this discussion right there but the fact
that Kira when it boils down to it is
simply just a guy very much a realistic
depiction of a serial killer actually
because when these people are caught in
reality the story behind them is often
exceedingly normal and even boring you
know they tend to have family stable
jobs and a lot of times even actively
involved in their community whereas the
large majority of media portrayals of
serial killers MO like individuals who
live in dank rooms licking knives and
endlessly fantasizing about their next
kill
it's a strange evil for the sake of evil
stereotype and I'm sure that there are
serial killers like that maybe but Jojo
at lodge has a horrible habit of falling
into PO stereotypes with villains the
most well-known antagonist EO can be
boxed in like this because he has a bit
of a flat existence to me because he's
just a profound jerk for no real reason
and because of that my expectations of
him were always quite low whenever he
shows up I know that he's going to do
something shocking for the
sake of shocking with no deeper
character motivation behind any move he
performs so I wait for his dickish
maneuver to happen and then we move on
however Kira is the kind of character
that you can never have any form of
solid expectation the majority of his
actions are performed with one clear
goal in mind settle this as quickly as
possible and return to a state of
normalcy he will almost never commit an
unnecessary action so we don't get a lot
of evil for the sake of evil stuff from
him you know like killing a cat while
freezing time which means that when Kira
does act it is always much more
dramatically potent because if he's put
in a situation where he needs to do
anything at all it is automatically a
desperate one and this gives him a lot
of room for exploration as a character
as opposed to most of the antagonists in
the series because we tend to focus more
on cure as minut actions and subtlety of
mind and we are being consistently kept
on the edge of our seats wondering if
and when Kira will be pushed to a state
of invoking his power at all and I don't
think I can really overstate just how
effective this is in crafting a villain
because if you look at other Jo Jo
examples and let's use someone who isn't
dear let's let's say cause this time he
isn't accepted evil who has no
restrictions on his actions with an
eventual goal of world domination and as
a result of that we are not paying
attention to his subtlety because every
time he appears he needs to do something
grand just to make him the baseline of
an interesting character and even after
going so far as to become the ultimate
life form I'm still not so sure that I
would ever easily accuse cars of being
interesting and that's because Yoshi
carga Kira is capable of generating more
drama from a mix-up of sandwich bags
then causes by presenting an apocalyptic
scale threat to the planet there's just
something so incredibly absurd about the
idea that cars by virtue of his
characterization has to work so much
harder to have any impact as opposed to
Kira who every moment he spends on
screen or page is simply gripping and a
lot of that might primarily be because
the problems Kira faces are
fascinatingly mundane and far more
identifiable as a result because putting
aside the whole serial killer with a
dismembered hand fetish I'm sure that
most of us can probably empathize with
Kira to some degree especially the
introverts amongst us who face the daily
challenge of just trying to keep life as
quiet and as in control as possible
while still of course pursuing what
makes us happy whatever hobby that may
be Kira just so happens to be a twisted
personification of that but it doesn't
make his struggles any less identifiable
if anything it makes him uncomfortable
relatable incapable of generating both
disgust and an L
of sympathy or empathy and that's very
conflicting set of feelings to deal with
which can mean that whenever cure
appears we'll be paying just that little
bit more attention because we are
constantly in search of new information
to properly make up our minds about this
character and there are very few jo-jo
antagonists that I would say I feel
similarly about in comparison my mind
was more than made up about do cars and
Rico and Diavolo within mere minutes or
even during their proper introductions
and a lot of this comes down to a very
simple core idea of what makes a good
villain which is that your Chicago Keira
actually believes that he is the
protagonist of his own story he will
murder without a second thought
still complete identities and families
and still believes that what he has done
is a perfectly acceptable action albeit
not socially acceptable and yeah I guess
you could make the argument that people
like do see themselves as the
protagonists of their own story but the
difference is dear knows for a fact that
what he is doing is wrong he's to
cartoonishly evil not to understand that
and in his case it's more that he
embraces the evil within him and that is
the source of his charm
whereas Kira's charm is that he believes
his evil to be regular mundane behavior
and with this unique positioning Araki
elects to take maximum advantage of
Kiera in a way that he had not done
before and arguably has not done since
because we spent quite a lot of time
during Diamond is unbreakable following
the story of Keira and in a weird way he
becomes something of a protagonist
during the second half of the series and
one particular experience that comes to
mind is where he even has his own arc
and a link stray cat this is like six
whole chapters in the part for manga
which doesn't even feature any of our
actual protagonists that's a pretty big
thing to be capable of as an antagonist
because yeah most of them get a handful
of chapters here and there focusing on
them but with Keira it honestly gets to
the point where we start zeroing in on
him more so than josuke
well actually any protagonist which is
such a departure from what Jojo usually
is which likes to keep the main villain
in the background until the designated
time of battle and speaking of in
keeping with Kira's kind of normalcy as
a character his final battle certainly
does fall short of JoJo's more epic
expectations it really is more of an
intimate affair but josuke just stumbles
upon him in the street and things
cascade into chaos and defeat from there
the fight itself is not anything that I
would come close to calling a spectacle
and did his fought and won almost
entirely in the mental arena pitting
Keira against josuke in a war of ideas
and quick thinking and Keira doesn't
have a particularly epic death either
having been accidentally run over by an
ambulance intended to save his life
but at the same time it's all just so
appropriate and satisfying of an ending
for such a character he doesn't need to
stop time-warp the universal present the
pinnacle of power and so he doesn't
really need to be defeated in such a
fashion either and with that said his
ultimate or eternal fate is
exceptionally satisfying with his last
interaction being with the ghost of a
girl that he had previously killed and
then being dragged into god-knows-where
by Kyra's favorite item in the world
being hands and I don't think I've ever
felt more content with the defeat of a
jojo villain than i have here well
perhaps in fact villains in general
Kira's final moments here is one of the
most memorable antagonistic endings that
I feel like I've ever experienced and at
this point I do want to note that rather
ashamedly I have not yet read dead man's
questions so I'm not quite sure how his
story continues from here however for
the sake of this discussion I think it's
unimportant because kara does not need
extended media to solidify his presence
in this universe and something I haven't
spoken about yet would be his stand
Killer Queen and how this makes Keira
infinitely more interesting because it
would seem that its effect operates in
such a stark contrast to everything it
is that Kira strives for Kira is a quiet
clean and unassuming man yet his stand
power is mostly about creating messy
messy destruction so it creates an even
bigger conflict of interest leading to
maximum drama because Kira can't really
invoke the stand without making
something of a scene so he has to use it
very selectively and precisely with the
slightest lapse in judgment resulting in
a situation that can get very quickly
out of hand pun intended like the whole
situation with Joe taro and Koichi and
it's really cool to see his stands like
this in the hands of a person who will
arguably never use it to its full
potential
obviously he bites the dust aside
because that's a pretty insane
invocation however what I'm trying to
say is that if Killer Queen were under
the control of most other villainous
presences then they would probably use
it to [ __ ] the world but at the same
time I also feel like it would be used
far more boringly than Kira's more
creative and selective invitations but
one of the points I'd like to end on
regarding Kira is that he also isn't
necessarily presented to us as an
irredeemable character and I do wonder
how his story would have turned out if
Hayatou didn't exist and I wonder this
because this is really kind of a
sickening situation but after assuming
the identity of Kosaku Kawajiri it
actually brings a massive degree of
happiness to the life of Shinobu and
Kira begins expressing dare I say it
concern for his new wife safety and this
even confused Kira himself who tried to
rationalize it as simply not wanting an
event to occur that would put undue
focus on him but there is no doubt in my
mind
while small the seed was planted that
probably would have eventually gone on
to irrevocably change Kyra and look
redemption is probably too strong of a
word because his actions in life thus
follow nothing short of putrid
self-serving and cruel but he was
undeniably evolving and maybe had this
gone on Kira doesn't evolve into a good
person who loves his wife and stops
murdering women for their hands but he
would have changed in some way well
maybe he reaches an impasse where he is
forced to make the decision to kill
Shinobu because his feelings for her are
compromising who he is and come on we
all know that those hands of his get
mighty jealous but the point is that
even right up until the end of his
tenure Kira is presented with options
and potential lots of potential so much
so that I could not help but want to
follow his story like it was an
addictive soap opera which is not only a
greater endorsement of him than most if
not all of the other jo-jo antagonists
but also the majority of the
protagonists as well very few of our
JoJo's are as well explored as yoshikawa
Kira you could even make the argument
that none of them are although that's a
very different topic but the fact that
Kira can even stand in their league is
nothing short of phenomenal for a guy
who just wants to live quietly in a
small pocket of his own private space so
in my opinion yoshikawa Kira is a master
class of character development and
implementation and nothing short of an
absolute highlight of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure but that pretty much does it
for this discussion on Yoshioka Kira if
you enjoyed this video in the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the new
world review patreon because the support
of all of you amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patron isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
sports channel an incredible amount and
if you'd like to join the fun at any
time and please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
Shannara takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts on yoshikawa Kira this has been
the new world review and I'll see you
next time
you
[Music]